that Smithsonian's National Museum of
african-american history and culture is
opening a new exhibit this week to
celebrate the life and career of Oprah
Winfrey Gayle is in Washington where she
previewed the watching Oprah exhibit
with Oprah Winfrey yesterday
hi Gayle good morning that sounds so
cool doesn't it that watching Oprah
exhibit with Oprah but John this is what
I'm thinking at this moment I really
really wish I had your word Smith skills
at this moment so I could put into words
how I feel
yesterday and today and walking into
this room and seeing it again it's
humbling it's overwhelming and in
Oprah's words it's surreal so how many
people are alive who get exhibits that's
what Oprah asked as we walked through
the 4300 square foot Smithsonian
exhibition showcasing the artists that
shaped her and the culture that she
changed forever she is receiving this
rare honor for her extraordinary impact
an extraordinary is a word I have to say
on the millions of viewers around the
world
who tuned in weekly for more than two
decades we were with her when she saw
the exhibit for the first time Wow
where the tour from the best museum
director girl could have Lonnie bunch
[Music]
basically what we've got here is how the
world shaped you so we're really free
civil rights hero because 1954 I should
say this I was born at the right time I
was born when the Supreme Court ruled
that segregated public schools were
unconstitutional even though things
didn't turn around immediately it was a
sense of hope and change so even that's
no accident that she was born that year
when you look at the video honey yeah so
what I love though is to both give you
this give people the sense of how you
were shaped by that but also how you
were shaped by the medium and first time
I saw the Supremes on the Ed Sullivan
Show as its as a ten year old girl I
went color people on color people on
calling everybody and it was the first
time I realized you could be a beautiful
black woman on top
well there aren't many things that can
withstand the test of time and this is
when I was doing my own hair yeah that
was when I was afro for like seven years
after your hair fell out all my hair
fell out yeah not a straight make up
lord have mercy wait what's this letter
with Lonnie this is the night before the
show exactly eight hours before the
national first show I keep wondering how
my life will change if it will change
what all this means why have I been so
blessed maybe going national was to help
me realize that I have an important work
or that this work is important I just
know that I must be pressed to the mark
of the high calling I know I was so
nervous that day I had hives under my
armpits oh no this show always allows
people hopefully to understand the power
they have it was a very first show but
don't you marvel at the consistency of
her the very first over a new show to
help people show the power they have to
change their own lives that's what you
said on the first day I really believe
that you've opened this world of
possibility where people are wrestling
with issues they never wrestled with
people feel that they can change their
lives in part because of the workers oh
the beating of Rodney King came into our
living rooms and smacked us in the face
there have been opportunities to talk
about race rights but you rarely talk
about race across racial lines yeah and
so for me because of the confidence
people had in you people would listen
and engage where they wouldn't another
another venue you are a peacemaker
inside yourself we're gonna start a book
club on the show in the audience listen
to me carefully is being given a special
package and I don't want you to open it
now I do remember the night before you
were trying to decide what to wear I
wanted to tell it with Max Bose on the
car
[Applause]
all right there was a lot of thought I
love this mural of every show you've
ever done with the dates and everything
so she's done every show from the
Oakland winfrey show four thousand five
hundred and sixty one and Loni number
one the whole time I really do believe
that I can't think of anything that was
as transformative during those twenty
five years as your show I can't think of
it I really can't I thank you for saying
that because I do believe that we had a
big impact on the culture and I continue
to feel that from people every day and I
want to show you something where you'll
see it even though a journalist wrote
this look at this Oprah Winfrey and
Gayle King inspired my decision to
become a journalist Oprah bought my
family together we would all crowd
around the TV to watch a woman do what
we could only dream of doing she gave me
hope that I too can be on TV a strong
black woman like her wow this is amazing
yeah Oprah Winfrey is the reason I love
myself so fiercely you know that my
voice matters oh that makes me want to
cry the bottom line is this was your
gift in our gift to America and so we
want to thank you for that for doing
just that it means a lot to us Wow that
exhibit opens to the public on Friday
and that's a moment that God everybody
was fine walking through because we were
marveling it really was a great trip
down memory lane but when Oprah hears
from people directly the impact that she
has on them that instantly is a game
changer for her and just this morning
guys in the car the guy who's driving me
this morning his name is ií'd he's from
Pakistan he said he came here in 1992
because he heard that we were talking
about Oprah he was started watching The
Oprah Winfrey Show and he would see her
walk in the aisle with the audience and
some of the issues she would cover she
would cover and he said I just knew that
she was a good human I'm so sorry
because I'm so used to talking about her
but it's a way that he said it this
morning and when I say all the things
that
or in this room it it is getting to me
and at the bottom line she really is a
human who just wants to do good in the
world and this exhibit is a testament to
that I have to say special shout out to
Amy wine bloom who's Oprah's chief of
staff who I know this isn't the kind of
thing that Oprah would have ever done
for herself and Amy just stayed on it
stayed on it bugging or bugging her that
points when Oprah would say just leave
it alone I don't want to do it no no no
no
thank you Amy wine one for that and the
staff here RIA and Kathleen who put this
thing together and I didn't even call it
a thing it's beyond amazing what has
happened in this room and Gail everyone
just say sorry no I'm so glad you share
it with us guilt because I know but
Oprah was going to go down the other day
and view it by herself and you said no
no no let me come down and do it with
you let me take it that was so brilliant
because Gail yeah well it was it was
Ryan Carol's idea so thank you Ryan but
I've been there from the beginning until
so to see it like this I am full and I'm
so proud there's nobody like her and
you've got to come see it it opens on
Friday see it